in the center of every galaxy is a
supermassive black hole a black hole
that can be millions or billions of
times the mass of our Sun that a kind of
the most extreme object in the universe
and sometimes they collide with each
other this is something unfortunately
you'll never be able to see directly
because they don't give out light that
black holes but you can see them through
the gravitational waves that they give
out and in 2034 we'll be launching a
spacecraft into space which will be a
giant gravitational wave detector
it's called Lisa the laser
interferometric space antenna and the
facts around this mission are so cool
and the stuff we'll be able to discover
incredibly cool so I wanted to do a
video about it you probably remember a
few years ago we had the very first
detection of gravitational waves which
science has got very excited about and
with good reason everything we know
about the universe so far comes from
light going from radio waves through
visible light through to gamma rays
that's everything we know about space
gravitational waves opened up a new way
to look at space and they saw mergers
between black holes and other black
holes of black holes and neutron stars
and I've done a video about that
detection of gravitational waves which
you can see here but the brief summary
is there are two detectors in the u.s.
called LIGO and one in Italy called
Virgo by combining them all together
they can make detection z' and see the
direction that gravitational waves come
through their interferometers which
means there are an L shape they send
lasers and bounce them off mirrors and
then they check what happens when those
lasers interfere with each other if
there's a change in dimension of one of
the arms they can detect changes in size
ten thousand times smaller than a proton
which is just insane
also since they've been turned on
they've done a bunch of detection runs
and in the last run they were seeing a
gravitational wave signal on average
about once every 5 days which means that
black holes are merging incredibly
frequently far more frequently than we
really expected before we started doing
those measurements so for a long time
people have wanted to put a
gravitational wave detector into space
there's good
reasons for like you can make it huge so
at least it's gonna have a 2.5 million
kilometer arm length which is about six
times the distance from the earth to the
moon and also in space it's quieter on
earth ground-based detectors are
susceptible to wobbling around because
of seismic vibrations or a truck driving
past or someone sneezing which you don't
tend to get in space so that's why they
wanted to send it there trouble is space
missions are obviously very expensive
and prone to failure so they have to
make sure that it works really really
really well Lisa is a European Space
Agency mission run in collaboration with
NASA because it will be so big Lisa will
be able to see things that we just can't
see with the earth-based detectors you
can actually see a different frequency
range so Lisa will be able to see one
frequency range ground-based detectors
another and because they see different
frequency bands they're kind of a
complement to each other so Lisa will be
able to see the kinds of signals that
LIGO and Virgo see years and years
before they actually do the final merger
but the final merger will actually
detect with the ground-based detectors
the coolest thing that Lisa will be able
to see is the merger of supermassive
black holes because supermassive black
holes are the cause of galaxies they'll
probably be surrounded by gas so if we
detect gravitational waves that look
like a supermassive black hole merger we
can look to see if there are any x-rays
coming from the same event which we will
do in the future with the Athena x-ray
Observatory Lisa can tell us the
direction of sources to an accuracy of
about a square degree this observation
would be cool because it might explain
the high energy Jets we see coming from
the cause of certain galaxies we might
even be able to see one of these Jets
turn on which would be very exciting and
Lisa will also be able to see the
absolute distance to things which is
very useful to calibrate other distance
measures that we use like Cepheid
variables or supernovae Lisa will be
able to make an independent measurement
of the Hubble constant more accurately
than any current technique and be able
to measure it in an epoch of cosmic
history where other measurements aren't
available the Hubble constant is a fan
datian of our model of the universe and
how it's expanding so it's a very
important thing to measure accurately
also gravitational waves don't really
get absorbed by anything as they travel
through space so if they're a signal
strong enough Lisa will be able to see
out to the very edge of the observable
universe and as you're looking further
away into deep space you're also looking
further back through time so Lisa will
allow us to study the history of how
galaxies form from the early universe
through to today and Lisa theoretically
will be able to see tiny amount of time
after the Big Bang so something like a
billionth of a second or even shorter
after the Big Bang and we don't know
what we'll see there but it could lead
to new physics it could lead to us
understanding how the forces of nature
emerged maybe we'll detect some signal
of new forces of nature or test theories
that we have like cosmic super strings
which is something no other current
technique can do and it'll also be able
to see orbiting white dwarf stars in our
own galaxy now how does Lisa work well
it's made of three spacecraft arranged
in a triangle and the spacecraft of
flying informations that they stay
exactly the same distance away from each
other each one has two gold platinum
cubes in the middle which a test message
which are essentially mirrors which
bounce the lasers back and forth from
the other spacecraft and those test
masses are protected from radiation and
particles from the outside space by the
surrounding spacecraft which has got
micronewton thrusters so it whatever it
gets a bump from somewhere it it moves
back so that inside the spacecraft it's
completely undisturbed so it's really
exciting that we're going to be able to
use this detector to probe into areas of
physics that we've never had access to
before and it's going to launch in 2030
for which it's quite a long time in the
future but they've already launched a
mission to test some of the technology
it's called Lisa Pathfinder and it ran
from March 2016 to June 2017 and the
critical part were these
- 2 kilogram test masses which they
tested to see if they could just have
freely falling through space protected
by that external spacecraft they
characterize the different sources of
noise in space things like gas particles
within the actual spacecraft you're the
big part of the mission are the optics
of the laser beams they tested the
optics and found that it's a hundred
times better than what they need so now
that they know the technology is gonna
work they're building Delisa probe and
although we have to wait until 2034 I
think it's going to be worth the wait
because I think this technology has got
the it's going to be as a revolutionary
something like the Hubble Space
Telescope the big thanks to the European
Space Agency for letting me use a load
of their cool animations in this video
and a special thanks to my patrons and
people buying my posters this channel
simply wouldn't exist without your
support and so I really appreciate it if
you want to help me make more
high-quality science content you can
check out my patreon at patreon.com
slash domain of science and you can get
my posters at dftba for North America or
RedBubble
for the rest of the world where I've
made some of my posters available in
French and Spanish links to all that in
the description below and thanks again
for watching